Hi, Evan, how are you?
How you doing?
Yeah, I'm doing good. How's everything going on your end? Yeah, kind of, kind of like a very busy weekend and when I was coming back today, I was feeling like, oh, I'm coming back after a very long time.
Good weekend.
I think it's good.
Yeah, it was just a weekend, but it felt like a weekend as long. Father's Day stuff though. Did you do any Father's Day stuff, your dad?
No, my dad passed away in 2021, so obviously it was a bit hard for me.
Yeah, no, sorry to hear that.
It's OK, no worries. Hey, Jennifer, how are you?
I'm good, how are you doing?
Doing good. How's everything going on your end?
It's good. Ready for summer to be here full force though.
Kip.
Okay, so what did you guys do yesterday?
My family went to the beach, so we spent a nice day on the water with some friends.
Wow, great. Aren't you?
took my kids fishing, so we just went fishing to like a little river that kind of runs through the town. We sat there for a bit and then after that we went and just got some ice cream and just had a nice little afternoon. It was good.
How great, great to hear that. I was busy traveling, so I had to travel. So I visited my, how do I call it, like in India we are very close knit in relationships. So yeah, we do.
Yeah.
Where'd you go?
We do stay with families and everything. So I still stay with my mom. My father is no more. So my sister's father-in-law, we visited them yesterday. So that was a trouble zone. I was trying to think, how do I put it up? Yeah, it was a.
I'm sorry.
Nice to go see family.
Priya.
Mhm.
So that was it. Let's start. Thanks for joining in. Thanks for making it OK. The agenda says the same. No changes. Overall, Kian and Pam are progressing well. Both are showing great engagement towards work. I had a discussion with Pam and Kian as well.
And they're both actively invested in growth, specifically as like, how do you see yourself growing here in ITBD by design as well as in F2? So both said that we are...
keen and invested in growing, we want to move to an L2. So explain them because I had this discussion with the other teams as well. How does anyone progress to L2 layer? So explain it to them. Yeah, they said that, okay, we'll see how this goes because I said like.
At least there are two minimal conditions. One is you need to spend one year at least in F2. That is 1 major condition. Second thing is there should be an open position within F24 and NL2.
Yeah, so definitely they are very keen and Western and growing. Okay, what feedback do you have for both of them?
From like Keon's perspective, he is absolutely doing a fantastic job on the CSATs. He's our, so we're starting to track leaders month over month. He's our leader this week. The words that the clients are sharing about him are just wonderful. One of the clients says, you know, it doesn't, I've read exactly what the quote was, but it was something along the lines of it doesn't matter what the issue is,
Yeah.
I know if it gets to Ketan, it's going to get taken care of. And that really just embodies exactly what we're looking for from the team is just to instill that confidence in our clients. Even if they don't have all the answers, just that, you know, Ketan has the ticket, he'll get it taken care of. That is, that is absolutely amazing. I was so happy to see that I shared it with him as well.
Oh.
Great, great to hear that, and Pam.
Pam is a rock star. Like she is just jumping into everything that we ask her to give a try to. She's starting to help others on the team with next steps, which is really nice to say. And I would say from my perspective, moving into that TTU role or LTU role, like that's what I'm looking for, right? Is are you now contributing to helping other members of the team?
from a technical or client perspective. So she's starting to do that, which is really nice to see. She's, I would say she's willing to try just about anything with some support from our L2 user, Aaron. Aaron, I don't know if that's a fair assessment or not.
Okay.
No, so that's true. She's always asking for something a little more challenging, a little something a little tougher. So we give it to her, she does her best, she tries. She makes a good effort, she does research, and then if she gets stuck, she reaches out, but she's...
She's really invested in trying to grow and build that up, so it's nice to see.
I have one insight on that as well, but I'll cover that later when we move on the CSATS one. Okay, moving on next, no to dos from previous meeting, performance analysis, utilization is going good for Pam and Gian. That's good.
Yeah.
And ticket closures, I guess they're a bit low, but...
We're a low volume, so we're not going to have, you know, if you've got the Phoenixes or the Novas or any of those, like we just don't have that same kind of volume of ticket.
Yeah, so I understand things are going great in this direction. Now coming on to CSAT, both did not score 98% benchmark, but when I spoke with Mam, she said like she got an DSAT for an onboarding ticket and that's what I saw. And she said like,
Yeah.
Honestly, I was not aware of the process, so I said, okay.
We got this DSAT, now what's next? So she clearly said like, okay, I was giving the client these things, then he said like these are missing and that's what led to the DSAT. So this is 1 key thing that I think she understands why she got DSAT, which usually is missing in a lot of ticks.
wherein they do not see or understand the clear reason. So she got a research, she understood it. So that was great. And I asked, like, about the process. Do you know it now? She said, no, I know it. I know in and out. So this won't happen again. Now, the second thing, the Keith, like you said, like,
Okay.
He is invested more on doing things for himself. So this ticket specifically the 366 3234, he was invested more in troubleshooting. And by the time he escalated, it was already an hour, I guess. And that's why this triggered a DSAC.
second, 3672035. This was for an issue that was happening repeatedly. He resolved the issue, but he did not explain the user why this DSAT came. So why was this issue happening? And I guess.
Education was one thing if he would have done, that would have left to a CSAT instead of DSAT. Because generally if a repeat issue is occurring, we as in, even I would like to know why this is reoccurring, a little bit of education would have helped.
These are mine, right?
Sorry, which?
Yeah, and even so the last one, the 27035, that was more, so I did talk to the client with that one, that was more the client just being upset about having the laptop. It wasn't really a reflection on.
Yes.
Okay.
the tech at all, it was more, you know, upset on a hand-me-down laptop that...
that he was using.
Okay, so, okay. So was it not like that if you would have explained the issue or anything, this would have got into a CSAT? Was it something like this?
I mean, it certainly would have, you know, helped, or even just to flag it to Aaron and I to explain, you know, the use of hardware to the clients or to have our stakeholders over at the client do that, but I don't, you know, while it was a positive feedback from the client that he's got this, I don't know if Ketan really could have done a whole lot different on that.
Okay, great. Thanks for your support on this. So I guess Kian knows about it. You must have explained this to him already. Oh, thanks. Moving on next, this is the total attendance. So upcoming leaves.
Pam is on off on 19th and 24th June. 19th already gone and 24th June is something that's upcoming. She had planned this. I would tell you when honestly she said to me like, can I take these offs, please? I said, yes, for sure you can take it.
Yep.
So she said, like, how are we going to do this? Like, can I ask the, can I ask Jennifer and Aaron? I said, yes, if it's well in advance, you can go ahead and do it. So that was one funny thing. And on 1st May, she took an implant, but overall we have seen like things are going well with her.
Yeah.
some leaves in the beginning, but now things are going more in planned way.
Yeah, again, I think he's got time booked off in July if February is served. I think he's off for a couple of days.
Okay, like Ketan has been in the system for long, so he knows like he can communicate to me later. Yeah, but he had nothing in June, so that's why he did not communicate it to me. I'll check with him on the July. He leaves. He's communicating more to you than to me.
Yeah.
Okay, moving forward, I'll make sure like things go in this direction only you keep seeing these rockstars. And I don't think I need to work explicitly with Pam now because she is doing fantastically well. So I guess.
Both of the resources are turning out to be well, and Pam definitely.
Kip.
look forward or filled in Selena's shoes or maybe outgrew those shoes as well I would say.
Yeah, I think she's taken the role on and put her own version on it. And like the clients love working with her. You know, I enjoy just how eager she is to work with our senior techs, work with Aaron, learn new things, try new things. And Ketan, like, it's wonderful to have him on the team and just trust that he can handle the calls coming in.
he'll escalate when he needs to escalate or raise his hand if he's got a question about something. It's really, I think that's going really, really well.
Great, great to hear that. Aaron, you would like to add on anything?
No, I think I think Jain got it. They're doing great. He's been working well, reached out, just yeah, no complaints, just happy with the progress so far.
Oh, great. Great to hear that. So after a long weekend, I would say things are going pretty well for us. Yeah, happy to hear those comments.
Mhm.
Yeah?
Pre.
Happy to be able to see them.
Well, thanks. Yes. Yeah, we're happy to have the stability. Now, I think we can keep them. That would be perfect, right? No, we don't want them leaving at all.
Yeah.
No, no, this won't happen because I clearly checked with Bam and Khan on this aspect. There are no issues or challenges going to happen with them. That's definitely for sure. I can vouch on that. Khan is specifically asked, so he said he has no plans of moving out.
or moving into a different company as of now. So as of now, I'm just assured like these things would go smoothly for us.
Awesome. So they're happy on this team and they're feeling supported by the team.
Yes, yes, for sure.
S.
That's what we that's what we like to hear, 'cause that's what we, you know, they need to continue to grow to is, you know, to be happy here and to be supported.
Yep, and they have really shown a great seal towards work. That's also adds one more thing, like they're really dedicated towards work.
Mm.
We appreciate that. I said, we're jealous of the coffee that Pam seems to get every morning on our huddle. Somebody brings her a coffee. We're all very jealous of that here.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's something that you can get in India, like people are there to serve coffee and tea.
That's pretty good setup.
I will take over that job, but I'm not doing this job anymore. But I want the same pay. I want what you're paying me now, and I'm just going to walk around and give everybody coffee all day. Can we do that? Can we set a thing?
Pre.
I don't think that's a thing, but...
That's probably nothing.
You had to figure out how to use the coffee machine then, Aaron.
A dream.
That's true, I don't know how to use that thing. It's way more complicated than anything I ever use.
As we, I think.
A small technical aspect, you just need to learn on that.
Yeah, this has got to be a manual I can read.
Yeah, and if there's anything else that we can be doing to support Ketan, to support Pam, please let us know. We want to see them grow and continue to do well here.
Yeah, as I spoke to them, like they they are seeing that they are receiving adequate support from you and Aaron, so that's a great thing, and they were naming some other team members as well. I forgot that those names, but yeah.
Yeah.
Probably Matt, Michael, Javier, Sebastian.
Yes, they were definitely taking those names and they are feeling great working with after.
Awesome. Good to hear.
Mm.
Thank you so much, Jennifer and thank you so much for your time. We'll meet next month.
Thank you for the check-in.
Vince.
Thanks.
We'll talk to you later. Bye.
Right.
Sure.